[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes petits amis
bonsoir il faut être très sage ce soir
car notre nounours et triste truste est
un tueur pas trop inquiet parce qu'il
n'a pas de nouvelles de sa soeur
emilia je lui jour que le nomma paul
pauvre nounours descend vite voir tes
petits amis ça te consolera ce petit
ange je vais vite patron hop hop hop hop
hop on le pleure plus mon fin tu vas
voir tu entends ton valent à lire
qu'elle est et c'est sûrement une led et
à mama bossoirs maison en chef au tarif
bien non
rémi toto et fanfan une grande lettre ne
sauve pas la lire oh c'est une lettre de
quelques couleurs alors ce sont de
bonnes nouvelles
venez vous asseoir autour de moi
[Musique]
c'est une lettre de peel hook redon
émergents votre maman moi aussi je suis
content j'ai été tellement inquiet mais
petit chéri vous me manquez beaucoup
cher mbia qu'elle te redonne j'espère
que vous êtes bien sage avec nicolas et
pimprenelle et avec votre tonton ici
tout va bien j'ai beaucoup de travail
car je profite de votre absence pour
faire tel que transformation dans votre
or dans votre chambre
j'ai ajouté un ravissant petit berceau à
ravissant petit défaut car mes chéris
vous allez bientôt à toi qu'est-ce qui
va livrer les veinards mais je vais être
encore tonton les enfants ne perdons pas
de temps
nous partons voir les milliards faites
vite votre valise
dépêchez vous car vous êtes les bodins
les chaussettes ornées baudoin des états
mobile au piano ce jeter mais des
aiguilles et de la laine comme ça tu
pourrais très côté des brassières merci
pas prodel tu penses à tous alors une
vue en route
drapé dans la valise pourquoi north
froid dans le ciel est comme ça ils sont
bien au chaud ah oui allons mes neveux
dit au revoir à nicolas et pimprenelle
et bilodeau de défend droit et voilà je
la ferme
sawyer aux finances mais que rien draps
de voir mais bien sûr mon petit nicolas
je vais juste embrassés et mia je lui
ramène ses fils et je reviens alors dis
lui à emilie qu'on aimerait bien la voir
c'est 3 mis à l'eau en août ma valise
que les lourdes au revoir les petits
or voilà nas
[Musique]
d'autant qu'elle vient d'avoir un petit
frère qu'est ce qu'ils vont bien
s'amuser
oui mais les pépés ça pleure la nuit ni
nicolas fait grève je prenais mais c'est
une merveilleuse nouvelle nounours sûr
que je suis content potro est bien en
route nounours mes petits amis
excusez nous de ce départ précipité nous
allons faire une petite visite à emilia
et nous reviendront vite vous retrouvez
ce promu tes neveux sont sages comme en
avant nos sources
bonne nuit les petits et grands amis à
bientôt à bien tous